it started because of two reasons one is
technology the the internet led to the
decline of advertising for print
newspapers and it changed how you can
watch the news as we had a proliferation
of outlets so you had conservatives
watching conservative media you had
liberals watching liberal media and
newspapers had no more money
the only way they got money was from
their average from their subscribers
and so they didn't want to alienate
their subscribers unlike an advertiser
who wanted you to appeal broadly to the
entire country so you have to be mindful
of staying somewhat
sensible and accurate
now you can let it rip
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
former white house press secretary a fox
news contributor and author of the new
book i've got in my hand right now
suppression deception snobbery and bias
why the press gets so much wrong and
just doesn't care ari fleischer welcome
to the reuben report dave thank you for
having me
ari i feel like you wrote this book for
me personally because this basically
gets to the heart of everything that i
do every hour that i spend working on
this show uh that the media is sort of a
bigger problem than almost anything else
at the moment uh but before we dive into
the book uh you have a really
interesting uh back story and all that
stuff how'd you get involved in politics
what eventually got you to the white
house and then we'll get into all this
stuff well to put in a nutshell it was
totally an accident
i i graduated from college i moved home
to play baseball and a friend of mine
had a brother who was managing a
congressional race they needed a press
secretary
i knew nothing and i got the job
which
tells you how little you need to know to
be a press secretary
and i fell in love with politics we lost
it was 1982
reagan stayed the course no republic
only one republican challenger won that
cycle
but i got the bug i moved to washington
i was unemployed and i got a job as a
press secretary to a new york
congressman and that began a 16-year
career on capitol hill followed by the
bush campaign where i moved to texas in
1999 and then the white house do you
miss being in the thick of the political
madness
no
nothing is there nothing you miss about
it
i spent 21 wonderful years in washington
and i loved every one of the days i was
there and especially at the white house
and when i was communications director
of the ways and means committee after
republicans took control of the house
tremendous excitement and satisfaction
but i was never a washington for life
type so one day you just know your day
has come it's time to go and it hit me
after 21 long years
so i loved it i loved standing at that
podium dave at the white house i loved
taking heat i loved catching the
curveballs the fastballs and standing my
ground on behalf of a president and a
person who i really believe in
and that's what it's about if you
believe deeply washington is the town to
be in uh and then go back home
believe it or not i watched many many
many of those press conferences that you
were doing back then they were sort of
must-see tv and and this will sort of
segue us a little bit to the book
correct me if i'm wrong the media
treats um republican press secretaries
and republican administrations a little
bit different than democrat press
secretaries and administrations is that
fair to say yeah i just caught friendly
softballs from the white house press
corps you know they love conservatives
they love bush look
the truth is as much as things have
changed since i was press secretary 20
years ago and they have changed a lot
they've gotten a lot worse and nastier
the fact is right now peter ducey is
really from fox news the only one those
49 seats asking hard questions to the
biden press secretary when i was press
secretary there were 49 seats asking me
hard questions
that's the problem the press takes sides
and they did back then but back then
david it was more just your liberal
conservative bias reporters still
thought their job at the end of the day
was be objective and tell the news fair
and not give their opinions on the air
today you watch cnn you watch almost
every show and they think their job is
to give opinions and that's what they do
and it's killing journalism so when do
you think that started because i think
anyone watching this they get it that's
what i spend most of my show doing at
this point is debunking a lot of the
nonsense that cnn new york times
washington post that they're putting out
as fact when if you just read the
headline with a little more a little
more precision you will see that it
actually is opinion yeah absolutely
right look it started because of two
reasons one is technology the the
internet led to the decline of
advertising for print newspapers and it
changed how you can watch the news as we
had a proliferation of outlets so you
had conservatives watching conservative
media you had liberals watching liberal
media and newspapers had no more money
the only way they got money was from
their average for their subscribers
and so they didn't want to alienate
their subscribers unlike an advertiser
who wanted you to appeal broadly to the
entire country so you have to be mindful
of staying somewhat
sensible and accurate
now you could let it rip and along came
more social media twitter and other
places where reporters felt really good
given their opinions
they didn't value objectivity anymore
they wanted them water followers they
wanted the praise of hollywood actors
and actresses when they let their
opinion read hence jim acosta at cnn
john harwood at cnn daytime reporters
who don't report they opine and always
from a far left point of view anti-trump
anti-republican and then the other
factor was trump
when trump emerged the press
somehow
made the decision to save the republic
they decided the american people erred
in 2016 by not electing hillary and the
press was going to fix the mistake
so these snobs put themselves in a
position superior to the people and said
collusion is probably how come trump won
the steele dossier is credible and we're
going to put trump in the country
through years of misery to make the case
against him and you know as i write in
the book they didn't put just their
finger on the scale they put their
writing hand on the scale and many of
them put their entire bodies on the
scale
and this is the mainstream media today
and that's why i wrote the book david
this is why i blew the whistle on the
press
i try to be fair
i will always call the balls and strikes
i supported president trump on policy
pretty much all the time
i regularly tweeted that i objected to
his behavior when he tweeted something i
thought went too far and was offensive i
called him on it but when i saw the
coverage of donald trump how biased
unfair get trump if it was anti-trump it
gotta bump coverage i said i'm gonna
write about this it's not good for the
country it's not good for democracy it's
not good for journalism when reporters
are in the tank
do you think that they would have done
the same thing to your guy george w bush
had social media been as big back then
because i remember very specifically one
day i used to live on the upper west
which is you know bastion of liberalism
columbia u and i remember during the
bush presidency and it was during the
iraq war when the media was going crazy
all the time and you were you were doing
the press
press junkets and all that stuff i
remember walking out and there was a guy
with a table with books and i remember
every single book basically was george w
bush is the devil like every single book
and they were all being bought of course
and had social media existed at the time
my guess is they would have done the
exact same thing it just would have
happened earlier yeah i know you're
right about that and i think one of the
points i make in the book is regardless
of what president trump decides to do
whether he runs or doesn't run they're
going to do it to ron desantis yeah
they're going to do kirsty known they're
going to do it to ted cruz or tom cotton
and here's where i have some sympathy
for president trump what he will tell
you is republicans don't fight hard
enough and that's why he does what he
does
and i think there's some merit to that
because he recognized the mainstream
media is in the tank they're out to get
them they're not fair they're not
objective and so it made him fight twice
as hard three times as hard
i wish sometimes he had just gotten it
with a little more subtlety or nuance
but that's not his nature he let it rip
everywhere he went he was a bull in a
china shop and he took a new china shop
with him everywhere he went
um
and so
it's a calibration issue but yeah
republicans and conservatives need to
fight because my conclusion writing this
book is that the media has turned to
activists the mainstream media and by
that i mean the new york times the
washington post abc nbc cbs cnn
they are activists for a cause and it's
a liberal cause my first chapter is
called original sent yep and i went to
how much how many reporters are
democrats i i hired an opposition
research company
to go in and pull the voter registration
records of the white house press corps
these are public records anybody can do
it
and they discovered that by a ratio of
12 to one wow
white house are occupied by registered
democrats if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about the media instead of non-stop
yelling check out our media playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out the full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell